it's been seven years since our post
pandemic survivor duo showed up on our
screens for the very first time
and now they're back for another
adventure
we've finished the game platinum
and gave our review
and now this is our unboxing and first
impressions of the last of us part 2
ali edition and limited edition
playstation 4 pro console
and a couple of extra bonuses for you to
enjoy you know what to do
roll the thing
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everybody zacky here from geek
culture if you like what you're watching
do consider subscribing and smash that
notification bell icon so you can stay
updated to our latest geeky news and
tidbits it's no denying that the ellie
edition is the most coveted among the
several special editions of the game
having sold out since it was first
announced you're about to see why they
fly off the shelves like hotcakes the la
edition comes with a slew of physical
and digital goodies such as this full
size one to one scale replica of ellie's
backpack
the backpack itself can fit a 13-inch
laptop and still be able to hold
essential survival items plus you get to
show it all off to your cool cool
friends
[Music]
a patch featuring the game's logo
a 48-page mini art book done by the guys
over at dark horse
a life-size replica of ellie's bracelet
a set of six enamel pins that features
the last of us part 2 logo
a naughty dog logo a firefly logo
graffiti stop sign
ali's tattoo morph design
ali's signature weapon the switchblade
and the wlf logo
and you know we we can't say much about
the last one because
it's a spoiler and
we're being nice
a lithograph art print with an
accompanied forward by the game's
director neil druckmann
a set of five cool stickers
and of course the collectible steelbook
with two discs
which includes a data installation disc
and the playable disk along with a few
downloadable goodies such as the psn
dynamic theme 6 psn avatars
a digital soundtrack and a digital
version of the mini art book
a 7 inch vinyl record featuring two
original soundtracks of the game and you
can listen to those in another video
links in the description below and of
course the calling card above here
and
last
but not least
is the 12-inch alley statue that we have
right here it features incredible detail
and sculpting of our favorite heroine
wary and lonesome
sitting on a concrete block
playing her guitar
and boy does this look amazing
to the worn out texture of the guitar
and even down to the sculpting of the
bass
and i must say that naughty dog has done
a wonderful job and took immense effort
to put all of this together this last
point may sound a little subjective
but ellie's face does look somewhat a
little different
from the game
so
that's kind of like a minus for me
sorry guys
so that's it for the early edition let's
move on to the limited edition console
you know what to do
just
just roll a thing man
jeez
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
featuring a matte finish and a custom
engraved design of ellie's iconic tattoo
it also comes with a matching dual shock
4 wireless controller decked out in a
custom design of ellie's fern tattoo as
well as the game's logo in black on the
touchpad and white contrast detail
including white playstation shapes
on the buttons on top of that of course
is the last of us part 2 steel boot case
with the full game included and digital
content featuring the ps4 dynamic theme
a set of psn avatars
the digital soundtrack
and a digital mini art book from dark
course and if you really own a ps4 pro
or a ps4
you can still get the limited edition
workshop 4 wireless controller and this
wonderful packaging
fans of the game would definitely enjoy
this limited edition playstation
wireless headset perfect for total post
pandemic immersion and last but not
least we have the limited edition the
last of us part 2 seagate 2 terabyte
game drive perfect for those storage
savvy gamers that won't delete their
precious games
hoarder
optimized for both the ps4 and the ps4
pro the storage drive features ellie's
unique tattoo etched on it
and like most other seagate storage
drives
this one sports a small form factor that
gives it a good bit of portability
not only that but the last of us part
two's massive 100 gigabyte storage space
calls for a hard drive like this so ps4
owners can look forward to owning one
well that's all we have for today if you
guys enjoyed this video don't forget to
smash that subscribe button and hit that
like button as well so that other geeks
have a chance to watch this video and
don't forget to check out our spoiler
free review of the last of us part 2
links in the description below and at
the end of this video
until then this is zeki
wow
[Music]
oh